one question we get asked a lot is
whether you should use commercial
outlines or commercial supplements in
law school today we're going to tackle
the good and the bad of commercial
outlines in general we love commercial
supplements and commercial outlines and
highly recommend them in law school but
not all supplements are created equal so
let's go over the good in the bad we'll
start with a good first commercial
supplements help explain complex and
complicated subjects they are designed
specifically to provide clarity where
your professor is unclear they can
provide great summaries of important
parts of cases especially when an
outline is key to your particular case
book where an outline goes over each
individual case that you're likely to
find in the case book itself a
commercial outline can give you crucial
insight as to why certain cases are
important and what the important
takeaways are from that particular case
this is in fact the foundation of our
flipped case method which we talk about
in another video link down below but
commercial outlines are not perfect some
of the downsides include the fact that a
commercial outline might cover a subject
or a legal topic differently than your
professor but you should know that if
your professor has a different
understanding of the subject you should
go with the understanding that your
professor has your professor trumps the
commercial outline their version will be
on the test
not the supplement version another
downside is that a commercial outline
might confuse you it's possible that
getting a different version or
explanation might take something that
you understand and actually confuse you
so you have to be wary when you're
getting a whole bunch of different
explanations about the same thing you
have to be able to synthesize all of
that information but on the whole
commercial outlines are totally worth it
think of it like a pyramid you have to
have a solid foundation of the basics so
you can get to the higher level stuff so
think of it like a game of chess you
have to understand the foundations first
before you can move on to the higher
level strategies if in chess the
foundation is how every individual piece
moves you have to understand that
tonight
moves in an L shape and the pawn moves
one square at a time with certain
exceptions of course but you literally
cannot understand the second and third
level strategy without understanding
those basics and a commercial outline
provides that they also help you
understand what you are reading so many
law students dive into huge cases
without knowing why that case is
important and as a result they get
bogged down in verbose appellate
opinions this is why the average reading
rate in law schools is only ten pages
per hour it's also why it takes so long
to complete your reading assignments and
that's why we advocate for the flipped
case method where you read the
supplements first before you get to your
cases read you commercial outlines in
your upperclassman's outlines or Westlaw
case notes before starting the reading
of the case itself this will make you
read the case faster and with far more
understanding and it's one of the
reasons that commercial outlines are so
important you are not cheating if you're
using a commercial supplement I hear
this a lot there is this notion that
unless you do everything on your own the
hardest way possible you're somehow
cheating in law school using a
commercial outline is cheating in the
same way that having a piano teacher is
cheating I mean that is to say it's it's
not cheating at all you are also not a
failure if you use them to understand
your cases these cases are assigned in
law school in they're intentionally old
they're intentionally antiquated and
they're hard to understand so use
commercial outlines in a way that will
help you understand them in a way that
will help you retain that information so
that you can use it on the final exam
will also help you on your final exam is
our free guide to law school down below
in the free link and also you can check
out our masterclass on crushing law
school that will help you to destroy
your next law school final exam
step-by-step and it will show you how to
think like a lawyer if you like this
video hopefully you found it helpful
please click the subscribe button to our
channel we come out with new tips on how
to crush law school all the time as
always thank you for stopping by and
we'll see you next time on legal eagle
first the are created equal
[Music]
but their problems include more
difficult the the foundational